[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre sur tv 78
nouvelle édition de notre rendez vous
mensuel dédié au département des
yvelines son patrimoine ses loisirs ses
personnalités en un mot à sa richesse
avec moi aujourd'hui justin brasier
bonjour justin avec vous nous allons
parler du cabaret du bout des prêts
témoin la reprise de saison reprise de
saison en quelques mots un peu de
teasing de spectacles phares paru très
gris vous ne direz pas grave tout à
l'heure céline c'est votre première en
plateau bienvenus mon premier
appartement plateau vous à nous
présenter tout à l'heure les différentes
facettes de l'artisanat d'art versailles
m et oui c'est ça je suis parti à la
découverte des artisans d'art de
versailles et je vais vous montrer
comment on confectionne des chapeaux et
des sacs à main originaux voilà un peu
plus de détails un petit peu moins de
suspense mais un peu plus de détails
avec vous nicolas nous resterons à
versailles aussi et on va découvrir la
nouvelle exposition du château wilfrid
une nouvelle exposition sur les animaux
du roi donc des rois plutôt un louis xiv
louis 15 et louis saez et après je vais
vous proposer un petit jeu autour des
fables de la fontaine j'espère que vous
avez révisé les uns et les autres merci
nicolas dans le reste de l émission de
ce mois il sera aussi question
d'halloween organisée la veille de la
toussaint cette fête originaire des îles
anglo cette approche nous vous donnons
quelques conseils pour bien vous
préparer avec l'aide d'une des plus
grandes enseignes de déguisements d'île
de france elle est basée à plaisir
halloween il sera aussi question avec un
autre a invité le comte paul de la
panouse est le fondateur du parc
zoologique reçoit lé visiteur pour
plusieurs is kept game exceptionnelle
nous parlerons aussi avec lui de la nuit
des châteaux les prochains rendez vous
aussi qui arrivent et puis la direction
chambourcy ce mois ci pour notre défi de
la rédaction les équipes de tv 78 se
lancent régulièrement des challenge
sportif nous verrons qui a triomphé du
mur d'escaladé du centre apic donc pour
débuter à cette émission c'est un voyage
dans le temps que je vous propose avec
l'union et du commerce et de l'artisanat
de poissy depuis le mois dernier des
commerçants exposent dans leurs vitrines
des photos de leur boutique prise avant
la guerre des clichés qu'il est possible
de s'offrir sujet mis en image par
patrick jacques de dixmude
donc c'est un marchand chamiers c'est
exactement
l'emplacement de la bouche et une
rétrospective en images des commerçants
d'antan notamment d'avant guerre c'est
ce que propose l'union des commerçants
et artisans de poissy objectif animer
les rues sans photos ont été exposées en
vitrine des boutiques des clichés prêté
par un collectionneur locale on a fait
un choix à trois personnes 9 octobre
chez un collectionneur locale qui a une
collection de
plus de 1000 cartes postales et photos
des époques avant guerre et après guerre
dont il a fait le prêt de ses photos des
photos qui ont été proposées à 100
commerçants de poissy certaines ont été
positionnés à leur emplacement exact
mais on arrive pour pour exactement
trente huit commerces à retrouver
exactement
et on a même retrouvé des des grands
pères qui ont connu on les a en enfant
sur la photo en petit enfant d'ailleurs
de 6 ans on les a sur la photo ils sont
devenus grands pères demain qui a sur la
photo il a exactement 96 ans
actuellement les affiches sont
disponibles à la vente une expérience
qui devrait être renouvelée l'année
prochaine avec des clichés des commerces
d'après guerre l'équipe du cabaret du
bout des prêts près de cerner la ville a
retrouvé le chemin de la scène enfants
après une longue période d'absence ceux
liés à la situation sanitaire forcément
la nouvelle saison est donc lancée c'est
justin qui nous parle de sa
programmation exactement et pour cette
nouvelle saison wilfried le kabary va
tourner autour de deux spectacles phares
je vous le disais donc une nouveauté 1
et puis le spectacle est déjà dix ans
pourquoi déjà 10 ans et parce que le
cabaret fait justement ses 10 ans en
tout cas devait fêter l'année dernière
mais il a été repoussé en raison de la
crise sanitaire il y aura les meilleurs
tableaux des spectacles précédents et
voilà donc on pourra le découvrir cette
année mais ce n'est pas réservé aux
classes et vous nous en dit un peu plus
sur ce nouveau spectacle donc l'autre le
nouveau spectacle à l'affiché cabaret
quatre saisons c'est une comédie
musicale sur le thème du cabaret des
années 60 sur scène il y aura une
dizaine d'artistes pour vous en mettre
plein les yeux danseurs chanteurs et
comédiens le responsable du cabaret nous
en dit plus au micro de mélanie poquet
[Musique]
laissez vous tenter c'est un roman chez
soi où l'on veut
chanter des arrivées
soit vos lauriers
c'est l'histoire d'un amas pizzaïolo qui
est installée juste à côté d'un cabaret
et qui tombe amoureux de la meneuse de
revue du cabaret d'à côté est ce qu'on
ne sait pas c'est que ce pizzaïolo cette
histoire se passe dans les années 60 et
ce pizzaïolo en fait a toujours dit
qu'il offrirait une nouvelle pizza à
celle qu'il aime et s'avère que cette
pizza ces deux-là quatre saisons qui
n'existaient pas madame 60 et donc c'est
lui le créateur de la pizza quatre
saisons
et en plateau la chorégraphie a été
plutôt apprécié justin c'est un fou
voilà vous avez tout à fait le rythme
pendant la séquence les gens ne voient
pas tout mais ils doivent tous savoir
quels sont les les changements
principaux de ce nouveau spectacle alors
il ya eu plusieurs changements notamment
le kabar a profité de sa période de
crise sanitaire pour refaire des travaux
revend l'intérieur remettre leurs pattes
vous le verrez notamment le rideau et la
scène et les coulisses ont été changés
la mode qui était passé du rouge en
violet le rideau est passé d'un rouge à
un viol est tracé
voilà et puis un peu de travaux dans les
murs un peu de peinture comme dans la
loge que vous pouvez voir juste derrière
voilà qui mêle à des paillettes dans ses
murs pour cette nouvelle année 80 dates
sont prévues sur l'ensemble de l'année
donc des spectacles la moitié sont déjà
réservées en règle générale il ya dix
mille spectateurs par an informations et
réservations sur le site du cabaret du
bout des prix mais pour voir si la
chorégraphie et bien appris les uns
présent céline cette offre
est comme ça nicolas et cet engouement
gens font de la pizza et moi je la mange
très bien pour halloween est-ce que vos
costumes sont prêts vous allez me dire
ça dans un instant mais vous m'avez déjà
attendu le sait très bien merci en tout
cas si vous manquez d'inspiration
michael et demi d'euros vannes ou à
venir en aide il s'est rendu à plaisir
dans l'une des plus grandes enseignes de
déguisement de la région
[Musique]
halloween c'est dans quelques jours si
vous cherchez des idées de décoration
encore des idées de déguisements nous
sommes dans une boutique plaisir oise
c'est un parti
pour parler décoration catherine est à
mes côtés catherine quelles sont les
tendances 2021 pour halloween alors la
grande tendance cette année c'est la
décoration de table puisque on va
pouvoir recevoir être en famille ou
entre amis nous avons de très jolis
gamme que ce soit la gamme citrouille
toute mignonne les classiques exactement
où du de la tête de mort du clown des
choses ensanglanté et plein de petits
sujets de décoration et maintenant on va
partir pour les déguisements avec
plaisir
catherine on va donc passer aux
déguisements vous nous avez fait une
petite sélection chez les filles et chez
les garçons alors chez les filles qu'est
ce qu'on retrouve alors un petit top 3
avec le déguisement d'harley quinn qui
est un énorme succès puisque le film a
super bien fonctionné
un incontournable vampires bien
évidemment et quelque chose aussi
d'effroyables avec la 91e chez les
garçons alors chez les garçons bien sûr
on ne peut pas parler dans les queen
sans parler du joker il y a également le
personnage sow qui est très demandé
et toujours le clown ensanglanté qui
fait fureur pour halloween bon je vais
regarder ce qui ce qui me va le mieux je
vais faire mon choix faites votre
sélection c'est parti
[Musique]
merci catherine ça y est j'ai fait mon
choix ça sera le clown c'est un
excellent choix il vous aller à ravir
vous allez faire frayeur vous pouvez
aussi l'agrémenter avec le masque ou
alors vous faire plaisir avec une paire
de lentilles qui dont l'entrée de gamme
mais à 9 euros 95 et pour un costume
total ça coute combien en moyenne chez
fait sensation alors j'ai fait sensation
en à une gamme de prix très large qui
démarre de vin rouge jusqu'à plus de 80
euros selon les envies et le budget de
chacun merci catherine je passais en
caisse
merci notre champ
vous savez comment vous allez vous
déguiser nombreux sur la tribu
traditionnel citrouille que vous
déguisée en citrouille en citrouille
auteurs notent
les photos de la citrouille pour
prochaine émission je veux voir les
photos de voir ici on va rester dans
cette ambiance halloween avec nos
invités qui nous ont rejoint le compte
de lapanouse et puis à clémentine
sanchez aussi qui est responsable
culturel au château de thoiry bonjour à
tous les deux on est revenu toujours
avec plaisir que nous vous recevons on
parle d'halloween et de thoiry et du
château en même temps parce que cette
année il ya des escape game notamment
sur ce thème on va les détails et un
petit peu mais déjà je me tourne vers
pourquoi ce choix d'ouvrir de s'ouvrir à
cette fête aussi et bien parce que les
châteaux ont des fantômes eh bien il
faut bien les satisfaire eux aussi c'est
leur fête mais c'est clémentine dans par
le mieux parce que
elle a travaillé sur ce projet qui les
cryptes du compte a
été organisée tout pour moi je lui ai
pas fait le jeu est trompeur vous n'avez
pas participé à l'esc et il y en a deux
on fait un lien à partir de 8 ans qui se
déroule du 27 octobre au 1er novembre et
un second à partir de 12 ans mais avec
accompagnateur tout de même
entièrement permanent pour le kayak
riscle du compte qu'on espère le dur et
pour encore trois ans et c'est vrai que
pour l' esquive une familiale
élémentaire mon cher marquises c'est
quelque chose qui est beaucoup plus
ouvert à la famille certes cela n'a pas
empêché vous avoir peur pour une tous
les âges mais en fait entre guillemets
costumes entièrement château ont leurs
décors entièrement version halloween
toile d'araignée en ressort aussi pas
mal de vieux objets qui normalement sont
pas utilisés au public mais on se dit
que pour une fois on va faire plaisir
aux visiteurs et qui peuvent être au
plus proche des objets d'art tout en
faisant une bonne petite frayeur oui
donc ça se déroule dans le château
directement parce que dans les cryptes
du château est ce qu'on découvre des
lieux qu'on ne connaissait pas jusqu'à
présent dans la crypte du conte des
temps fermée dans les caves pendant une
heure très bien il a plus de raison de
sortir oui c'est ça surtout est-ce que
vous avez gardé des gens c'est ça la
question depuis ces quatre cent
cinquante ans
il alimente ensuite les animations du
château ça fonctionne plutôt bien
j'imagine que alors les escape game
marche plutôt pas mal mais c'est une
façon de découvrir touahri différemment
aussi de vous ouvrir aussi un autre
public et puis d'amener le public vers
le château connais beaucoup le parc
zoologique peut-être un petit peu moins
de château du coup toile et cetera de
l'histoire les théâtres de la nature
toit est un vaisseau dans à voyager dans
le temps qui a été sauvé par les animaux
sauvages et en prenant à bord des
espèces en voie de disparition c'est
devenu d'arche de noé il ya aussi les
nouveautés d annoter des lanternes et
howie housse et les animaux magiques et
donc ont rejoint les animaux rejoignent
le château puisqu'ils ont envahi les
jardins deux mille lanternes chinoises
alors le problème tactique locaux vides
les chinois les chinois pouvait plus
venir alors c'est mon genre qui est
parti en chine se fait refuser formée
dans l'année dans une ville qui ne fait
que ça un million d'habitants de faire
des lanternes et donc c'est pour ça
qu'on peut avoir une quatrième édition
avec deux mille lanternes dans des
lanternes géantes et puis ça monte dans
les arbres jusqu'à 20 30 m on voit
quelques images pendant que vous nous
parler de ses illuminations justement
des deux éditions précédentes là c'est
l'autre rendez vous qui se préparent
aussi 31 octobre au 6 mars à rennes 3 23
octobre j'ai eus nous sommes un à barran
êtes en avril alors par contre les skill
games et permanente oui l'année mais ça
c'est un succès formidable
et puis on avait les nuits du haut
château mais alors que c'est complet né
au château ça c'est le 23 octobre on
voit les autres autre animation
énormément de choses sur le château vous
fait vivre ce château qui redécouvre
aussi son public avec une année qui a
été qu'ils étaient compliqués une année
et demie qui a été plutôt compliqué donc
on parle maintenant de la nuit du 23
octobre c'est la nuit des châteaux et là
c'est la première fois que le château
s'ouvre pour cet événement est hautement
c'est assez particulier parce que c'est
un événement qui est national qui fait
un partenaire et d'artagnan qui met en
avant tous les châteaux qui souhaitent y
participer et qui font des visites
nocturnes donc nous on a décidé de faire
des victimes nocturne à la bougie qui
seront costumés en tout cas que les
guides seront costumes pour ce jour là
et nous allons aussi être complet mais
reste encore d'autres châteaux en île de
france par exemple dampierre qui lui
n'est pas encore complet donc c'est
vraiment un événement national qui
permet de mettre en valeur tout le
patrimoine français comme vous êtes
présent quand même un mot sur ce parc
logique comment se porte-t-il il ya eu
des nouveautés aussi puisque vous avez
accueilli la terre des gorille très
récemment il ya un rhinocéros nouveau
rhinocéros blancs qui vous a rejoint
aussi comment se porte le parc le parc
je parte se porte très bien et
il y a des grands projets que ma fille
qui est directrice scientifique du
groupe touahri départ une victoire et
préparer plus d'un autre jeune pdg
christel bercheny qu'un plein d'idées
donc nous on est en aaron est reparti
sur les chapeaux de roue santé cette
envie des français de se reconnecter à
la nature à l'animal ah oui l'animal qui
est en nous très important
je dirais pas
mais mais c'est si ces noms c'est très
important d'essayer alors quand j'étais
au collège ya très très longtemps 28 10
et aux profs de français well unité de
temps de lieu d'action c'est le théâtre
c'est pas la vie oui il n'empêche que le
théâtre c'est ce qui fait que quand on a
un problème affectif on prend pas sa
massue et on prend de la distance de
même chose avec l'histoire l'histoire
est très très mal enseignée en france et
c'est très important l'histoire parce
que c'est ce qui donne cette distance
les lauzes ans est il était pâle nos
grands-pères dépôts plus malin que nous
ils trouvaient pas mieux les solutions
mais la manière dont ils ont affronté
les situations ça nous aide à prendre
cette distance culturelle qui fait que
l'homme est plus capable il ya une chose
qui est la grande différence entre les
animaux les hommes quelle est elle c'est
que l'homme à l'univers pour territoire
et qui rêve d'éternité je suis
profondément européen parce qu'il ya le
satellite planck sa goody les milliards
qui a photographié l'apparition de la
lumière 380 mille ans après le big bang
il ya eu le l'anneau du cn avec le boson
de x à ccc l'europe et on oublie tout ça
et c'est pourtant tellement fantastique
il se passe il ya des créations tous les
jours jeudi c'est ensuite tous les mois
parce que c'est ça bouge et il faut
tirer par le haut l'écologie par le bas
où on retournerait et tous en vélo
dont tout le monde peut pas aller en
vélo par contre le progrès
est là et il faut en parler beaucoup
pourraient vous écouter pendant des
heures sous le monde s'est tu et tout le
monde vous écoutez je vais quand même
profiter pendant quelques minutes
supplémentaires pour parler des
différents ouvrages vous l'avez ramener
l'un de ses livres et qui présente
touahri son histoire photo magnifique
aussi dartus d'artistes boutin qui
participe avec vous ça aussi ça permet
de mieux découvrir l'histoire
quatre cent cinquante ans d'histoire de
ce château de thoiry et puis le parc
zoologique créé fin des années soixante
dix mots qui sont les plantes qui sont
nos frères et soeurs de cv de sens parce
que la molécule la molécule de la sève
et du sang
c'est quasi ses 24 atom dont un seul est
différent chez nous c'est le faire pour
ça qu'on a le sang rouge effet la plaie
chez les plantes c'est le magnésium dans
ce qu'elles sont en suicide je veux dire
que la généalogie familiale pour moi
elle va jusqu'à l'algue dont nous
descendons tous cours d'histoire cours
de science aujourd'hui et pour les
messieurs en 78 tours si vous venez de
nous rejoindre sur tv 78 vous propose à
tous les deux de rester encore un petit
peu avec nous nicolas va nous faire
découvrir une nouvelle exposition dans
un autre château celui de versailles les
animaux du roi on revient aux animaux et
on restera dans les châteaux puis c'est
une véritable rencontre en fait avec les
animaux qui ont côtoyé les trois rois du
château de versailles louis xiv ou 15
louis saez de nombreux animaux vivants
au château de versailles il y avait des
animaux de compagnie des chats des
chiens des oiseaux aussi avec notamment
l'animal préféré du roi il s'agit de la
poule sultane en regarder cet oiseau
teinté de bleu avec une crête rouge je
suis sûr qu'il va vous plaire wilfrid
j'attends avec impatience les images on
va voir tout ça on la voit là justement
la poule soul teintée de bleu la crête
rouge magnifique oiseau donc l'oiseau
préféré du roi y avait aussi la
ménagerie royale qui rôdent qui
rassemblait plusieurs animaux
exceptionnels à l'image de cette
éléphante puis la relation du roi avec
l'animal s'était aussi durant la chasse
à courre avec les meutes de chiens qui
pour chasser le gibier et pour attiser
votre curiosité regardez ces images du
début de l'exposition une entrée dans
une reconstitution du labyrinthe qui
existait auparavant à l'emploi - actuel
du bosquet de la reine écoutez c'était
un endroit jardin un jardin plein de
fantaisie animalière
c'était un lieu extraordinaire où vous
pouvez se perdre dans de grandes allées
de charmilles et puis des rocailles avec
des scènes tirées des fables d'esope et
des fontaines illustrer un certain
nombre de grands moments des fables avec
ces animaux magnifiques dont nous
conservons par chance un certain nombre
d'exemples plus ou moins abîmée mais ce
sont des chefs-d'oeuvre de la sculpture
du xviie siècle des sculptures en plomb
polychrome et on en montre une très
belle sélection ici je le rappelle donc
l'exposition s'appelle les animaux du
roi c'est une 12 octobre jusqu'au 13
février 2022 au château de versailles
est justement alors on entendu que ça
qu'on parlait des fables de la fontaine
parce que ces jardins justement cela
bien me permettait de découvrir les
fables d'esope et de la fontaine et bien
je vous proposais un petit jeu on va
jouer un jeu pour deviner les femmes je
vais vous dire les morales des fables
vous devez donner le nom de la femme
elle pense que je vais me baser
uniquement à me retourner vers le conte
qui va m'aider pense qu'il va que j'ai
souhaité répondre
les souvenirs de l'école parce que je
suis sûr que vous les avez apprise par
coeur les voiliers love bruxelles alors
première moral apprenez que tout
flatteur vit au dépend de celui qu'ils
écoutent
très bonnes réponses et ça fait le
corbeau et le renard on commence avec
des morale facile ensuite la raison du
plus fort est toujours la meilleure
le loup et l'agneau c'est sa troisième
fable un peu plus compliqué tel est pris
qui croyait prendre
pourtant elle est utilisé très souvent
dans leur langage quotidien elle est
issue d'une fable de la fontaine
cigognes les l'assiette la charge ah non
ça on va voir après arriver non
pensée un coquillage coquillages je
répondrai pas les séries en fait elle
durera et de l'huître donc forcément la
rame est vraiment là la peur c'est pour
vous que j'écris attendez-vous à
l'appareil et effectivement c'est ce que
vous avez dit juste avant c'est le
renard et la cigogne le renard qui
propose une assiette des miettes de pain
dans l'assiette à la cigogne et puis
balade cigognes ensuite qu'ils proposent
aux renards une sorte de l'ong flûte et
le renard peut pas aller chercher les
viets au fond et la dernière on a
souvent besoin d'un plus petit que soi
le lion et voilà bon bah bravo une fois
que vous n'avez pas donné beaucoup de
réponses oui vous propose de réécouter
l'émission quand même une ou deux une ou
deux d'après elle la réponse est
affichée tout à l'heure alors c'était le
prix difficile c'est nicolas céline on
resta à versailles aussi avec vous tous
les trésors de versailles ne sont pas au
château vous avez déambuler un peu dans
les rues royale à la recherche des
artisans d'art ébéniste chapelier
céramiste encore un restaurateur de
witte roos les professions qui n'ont pas
disparu et on peut toujours découvrir le
travail de ses artisans en effet moi
j'ai vagabonder dans les rues de
versailles à la recherche de ses
créateurs d'art et donc j'ai pu
rencontrer christiane schmitt christiane
schmitt est les modistes ça veut dire
qu'elle confectionne des chapeaux des
chapeaux de tous types elle fait des
chapeaux de cérémonie des borsalino des
bérets des bonnets et elle est
passionnée par ce qu'elle fait on les
écoute ça rend élégant ce que j'aime
bien quand on vient avec une toilette
ça peut améliorer une tenue toute simple
accessoirisé l'habiller la cliente
revient avec ses photos du mariage et
ses retours l'âme alors c'est magique
ils me disent tu qui vous a livré
quelques-uns de ses secrets c'est ça
alors elle a plusieurs techniques en
fait ils utilisent surtout un fer à
repasser en fait elle utilise la chaleur
pour donner la forme son chapeau en fait
elle part d'un feutre c'est un chapeau
avant la modélisation est en fait elle
applique le fer à repasser pour créer
une forme le modèle après avec ses mains
selon la forme qu'elle veut parce qu'il
ya plusieurs formes et elle fait la même
chose pour les petites coiffe en fait
les petites coiffe qui a le modèle sur
un patron avant qu'elle l'ait des moules
les ornent de plume de petites ornements
comme ça et je vais pas vous livrer tous
ses secrets bien sûr qu'elle en a
plusieurs mais elle est très attachée à
ce savoir faire qu'elle entend perpétuer
en tout cas c'est des métiers du passé
mais il faut aussi les maintenir pour
qu'ils restent dans notre présent et
dans notre avenir mais ça revient pas
mal parce qu'elle est les artisans d'art
seront remis en valeur on poursuit cette
déambulation ya plus d'une centaine
d'artisans d'art qui sont implantés à
versailles et je vous invite encore une
fois les les rencontres et la à présent
petit focus sur le travail de damien
béal oui j'ai continué mon chemin et
j'ai rencontré damien béal alors lui il
est menuisier maroquinier il a commencé
à 14 ans dans le domaine de la
menuiserie justement il a acquis un
savoir-faire fur et à mesure des années
qui lui permet d'être reconnu dans son
domaine voilà on écoute aussi à la base
je suis menuisier et je travaille depuis
huit ans sur l'idée d'associer
d'associer le bois et le cuir donc je
fais principalement de la maroquinerie
en bois et cuir alors la petite
maroquinerie au sac est lui aussi n'a
pas été avare en conseils et oui alors
utilise un petit merci pour créer ces
points de couture qu'il perce ensuite
avec une haleine ronde ce qu'on appelle
une haleine ronde ensuite il pratique la
couture scellier qui nous vient de la
famille hermès la couture scellier c'est
une couture à deux aiguilles en fait il
n'est pas à chaque fois dans le même
trou comme ça ça crée une sorte de
noeuds et c'est plus solide de ça qui
est beaucoup plus solide c'est un gage
de savoir faire de sa part pour les
finitions de la en sauce il utilise une
sorte de cire liquide qui lui permet de
donner un aspect plus cuir - brut à son
sac il faut savoir aussi que c'est ça
que vont se patiner ils sont forts en
caractère c'est à dire que la couleur
est voué à changer
voilà donc c'est très important pour
damien aussi de perpétuer de perpétuer
cet art pour lui on les écoute
appartement c'est travailler de ses
mains on sait pas quel sera le monde de
demain mais ce sera toujours utile de
savoir fabriquer des choses les créer
les concevoir les artisans à versailles
ils font un peu partie du décor
aujourd'hui en tout cas il le faisait
partie a très longtemps et à nouveau
aujourd'hui donc voilà si vous cherchez
à vous faire plaisir avec une pièce de
qualité où vous n'avez pas encore de
cadeaux pour noël par exemple vous
pouvez aller dans ses deux boutiques que
je vous conseille et sinon ils sont des
centaines à vous attendre merci beaucoup
céline merci aussi à nous inviter d'être
venu jusqu'à nous aujourd'hui a depuis
toi rire pour nous parler des nombreuses
activités que vous proposez nous parler
une fois de plus de la richesse de ce
parc zoologique et du château également
merci à vous et puis pour tous les
renseignements sur le site internet bien
sûr pour pouvoir vous inscrire notamment
aux escape game dont nous parlions tout
à l'heure on fait une petite pause et on
va parler à dans un instant de notre
défi du mois
[Musique]
deux journalistes de la rédaction on
s'affronte à chaque fois pour ce numéro
célia gars de son go présentatrice du
7-8 culture justin brazy présentatrice
du 7-8 journal ont été désignés pour ce
duel elles se sont rendus au complexe à
pic de chambourcy au programme de l
escalade
[Musique]
bonjour à tous nous sommes ravis de vous
retrouver pour ce nouveau défi des
champions justin je suis heureuse d'être
défié moi aussi alors dit nous nous
sommes et bien écoute célia nous nous
trouvons à un pic à chambourcy c'est un
complexe sportif 100% fun ou en fait on
peut trouver une trentaine de mur
d'escaladé 90 façon de les monter puis
il y aussi de l'accrobranche
[Musique]
on a des murs qui vont se rapprocher des
murs l'afrique mais on a également des
murs beaucoup plus fun et beaucoup plus
ludiques comme vous pouvez le voir
derrière moi on a des bambous sur
lesquels on peut grimper donc jusqu'au
sommet et ensuite se lâcher de tout en
haut donc c'est toujours l'idée du
dépassement de soi tous les grimpeurs
sont équipés de baudriers pour s'assurer
pas besoin d'être 2 grâce à un système
d'autos assurage sur le mode rit on a un
petit triangle avec une roulette qui
vont nous permettre
d'assurer de s'assurer d'accord
directement au bas du mur
[Musique]
maintenant commencer plus sur le concept
d'apic je vous propose de découvrir
d'autres des
le défi c'est le speed klein celles qui
arrivent le plus rapidement au sommet a
gagné cinq murs chronométrés
ça n'a pas trop le vertige si j'ai un
peu peur mais bon je vais tout donner un
organe patron bord n'ont pas non plus
long bon enfin que la meilleure gagne
quelle merveille allez courage c'est
parti je couve un pied et une main sur
le mur directement sur les prises une
main près du buzzer vous dites quand
vous êtes fret ou marque du bozar
la crèche oui 3 2 1
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et bien bravo à toutes les deux bravo il
n'y a pas photo vous êtes la grande
gagnante
merci beaucoup bon sinon bravo août
c'est bien on était bien à nous et on
s'est bien battu elles se sont pressés
les ébats une seconde près franchement
je n'y croyais pas moi même je suis
athée sur tf2 content
justin bravo mais vous n'avez pas gagné
non
vous m'avez le suspense comme ça je dis
peut-être du lait vous avez un doute non
on fait le montage mais elle s'est bien
battue un peu déçu du forcément moi
d'avoir perdu mais elle s'est bien
battue et qu'elle était méritée à s'est
bien battue et en toute modestie bien
sûr nicolas vous apprécierez ah bah oui
mais qui nous suivent habituellement
savent que vous êtes le monsieur
modestie de cette rédaction oui on l'a
vu face aux amicales et lui d'euros lors
du premier défi en formule 1 maintenant
voilà donc on a déjà deux vainqueurs et
des perdants qui sont les prochains
puisque la tradition veut que vous
désignez les prochains exactement donc
ces liens n'est pas avec mon plateau
mais j'ai son petit papier là je suis
déjà au courant mais je vous met le
suspense j'ai entendu des bruits en cas
d'action je n'ose y croire on a décidé
on a décidé pour la prochaine le
prochain magazine de faire un duel des
champions un diaby champion des chefs
champion des chefs très bien où la voilà
donc c'est à dire que s'il ya je les
laissais en bonne perdante choisir
choisir la personne qu'elle souhaitait
qu'elle souhaitait pour son duel et
c'est tintin
oui fritz et vous à ce sera moi très
bien il est là ce sera moi et ce sera
face à face à comme on a choisi annuel
des chefs j'ai choisi patrice carmouze
voit la vie en sera à vous de vous
battre là
on retrouve la bonne idée pour pour le
défi et ce qui ne serait sûrement pas du
golf je le dis tout de suite après
triste parce que je sais qu'il a un bien
meilleur niveau que moi qui ne touchent
jamais le club donc ça ne sera pas du
golfe on va trouver une image quel but
oui pourquoi pas du losc à saint bruno
plus facile pour moi merci en tout cas à
tous les trois d'être venu prochain des
filles donc comment leur enlever
maintenant ce sera pour nous le défi des
chefs vous l'avez dit on se retrouve le
mois prochain pour un nouveau 78 tours
[Musique]